now we know about a General Court I want
to think about two particular corners
two special coins which you've actually
met before on the parabola okay
inner ellipse this is any chord we like
okay so for example let's just draw a
quick
so a quarter is draining any two points
on the ellipse but if you think about
this kind here s right and I'm not going
to drop him in because it was just
MacLeod the diagram a little bit I've
got another focus obviously s - all of
the cords that pass through s like this
guy this guy all of his cousins right
because their cords and they passed
through the focus we call them vocal
cords we've met this on the parabola
right so firstly we look at the now I'm
not even gonna bother with the a drop of
this honestly because like I said again
before you can't quote it and in most
cases you'd have to do it in this
general form you'll actually get nothing
as rollers right all the way once
remember is a vocal cord is going to
pass through
now what are the coordinates of the
focus again if in terms of the
proportions and the eccentricity is just
going to be tiny comma zero right so
there's the first one or it's gonna pass
through yes - new a now you may recall
bless your question in the exercise one
of the handy things about this is number
one the reflective properties that we
know about vocal cords if you have a
look at this result any one of these is
going to reflect the cross and it will
hit the other fingers
that's plenty of us the other important
detail is all of the tangents you get
from those points of intersection and so
on they're not just random there let's
imagine it all going to land on the
directrix you may again remember from
proving that result from the parabola
okay of every tangent that you draw from
the end of a phone call every pair of
those are going to eat
dredgers okay and that's fairly easy to
establish you just go through the
knowledgeable so that's the focal cord
you need to remember it because they
will say the court is is photo answer
therefore what you could about it and
secondly I wonder if you remember
wondering this is a few memory is one
more special cord that we talked about
that you remember from the Prowler
there's quite a contact very good so the
court of contact how do we define the
court of contact what's that what is it
what's the contact talking about this
yeah yeah good in fact I kinda drove
over here if you get some kind of
external toilets let's give another one
here's an external point every external
point is going to have two tangents to
the ellipse right two tendons leaders so
there will be one that has a sharper
angle like that and intersect once and
then you have another one kind of a
shadow okay so now you've got from an
external point you've got two points of
contacts that your two tangents have and
of course what joins those points of
contact is the chord of contact
okay so just jot down a right then the
quad of contact is the chord for between
this weather of the freight that a
cultural it was for between the points
of contact
from tangents from an extent way
now this one will be very easy to
actually write down the equation or
because I want to remind you of a really
fancy piece of geometry that we show
dynamically on the parabola right do you
remember what happened as I took this
external point right and if I brought it
closer and closer and closer to the
ellipse as at this point gets closer and
closer to the ellipse what happens to
the two points of contact that's exactly
right so for example if I put a point
like that thanks to the plane obviously
the points of contact are going to be
pretty much one and two right in the
same neighborhood right and as I get
very very close to the ellipse these two
points of contact might be cosine a
cosine close up so this which if I
extend into both ways it sort of blows
through the ellipse so we would call it
a sort of an S will call the secant
right
that secret gets closer and closer and
closer to becoming a tangent right which
is right when we develop this formula we
eventually found out wait a second the
equation of the court contact is
identical to the equation of a tangent
at a given point it's just many
differences right
when it's off the ellipse or a point
that's on okay does anyone remember what
we Cartesian equation for a tangent it's
very simple it's very much like the
equation of ellipse yeah very good sir
I usually have x squared that's that's
my equation of the ellipse so for the
tangent I have X x1 but as a convention
if I'm referring to a point that's off
of the locus and a core x1 I call it X
all right so I'm at X X naught on a
square plus YY not on B squared equals 1
ok so that being the same as the
equation of the tangent to this ends up
being exactly the same and there's no
need to go through all of these because
if again you can't quote this you have
to go through this steps anyway so it's
not like we can prove this without them
all right we can quit from now on you
have to do some scratch every time it is
easier with numbers anyway